the st louis chess club is pleased to  announce the expansion of our  world-class chess facility  the 20 000 square foot expansion and  upgraded facility will feature new  ground-level classrooms supporting  players of all ages  as well as expanded tournament and  community gathering spaces  with state-of-the-art technology  accessibility upgrades including a new  three-story elevator  will provide access for all participants  and allow  even greater community engagement in the  great game of chess  as a proud resident of the central west  end neighborhood for over a decade  our hope is to build upon our investment  into the community  and solidify st louis as america's chess  capital and preeminent global  destination  for lovers of the sport we look forward  to seeing you in our new space in 2021  when we will host the 2021 u.s chess  championships  2021 u.s juniors and senior  championships  the sinkfield cup st louis rapid and  blitz and more